President Trump is tackling the
coronavirus response from Camp David
this weekend he left the White House
Friday after unveiling more details
about the administration's coronavirus
vaccine strategy pledging millions of
doses by the end of the year
meantime last night the House approved
another stimulus package totaling three
trillion dollars and for the first time
in the Chamber's 231 year history it
changed the rules to let lawmakers vote
remotely Nikole Killion is at the White
House this morning Nicole good morning
to you hey good morning to you Jeff that
new aide bill faces an uphill battle in
the Senate and here at the White House
where officials have dismissed it as a
non-starter and threatened a
presidential veto several Republican
lawmakers are accompanying the president
at Camp David and will meet with him
this weekend president Trump departed
for Camp David as a socially distant
House of Representatives voted in small
groups on the largest relief package in
US history the heroes bill is passed the
three trillion dollar Heroes Act
includes aid for local and state
governments the postal service plus
another round of stimulus payments and
hazard pay for essential workers the
Congress must honor its responsibilities
to the American people to lessen the
blow of the coronavirus we're here
talking about a speaker Pelosi's three
trillion dollar socialist giveaway plan
the resolution is adopted
the house also approved and miss George
rule change allowing lawmakers to
temporarily vote remotely by proxy and
hold virtual proceedings during the
pandemic vaccine or no vaccine we're
back and we're starting the process at
the White House the president set an
ambitious target to develop a corona
virus vaccine by the end of the year he
named former pharmaceutical executive
dr. monks of Maui and 4-star General Gus
Poorna to oversee the effort it's called
Operation warp speed that means big and
it means fast the president was flanked
by top health advisors including doctors
Anthony pouchy and deborah birx
had on masks so you can blame it on me
but I gave him the option we could wear
it or not the president said he didn't
wear one since they were outdoors and
everyone was tested but the rapid Abbot
test frequently used by the White House
recently prompted a warning from the FDA
for turning up false negatives great
test it's a very quick test and it can
always be very rapidly double check
overnight there was another shake-up in
the administration CBS News has
confirmed the State Department Inspector
General Steve linic is being fired the
fourth IG to be let go
in recent weeks House Foreign Affairs
Committee Chairman eliot engel says the
watchdog opened an investigation into
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and
accused the president of an unlawful act
of retaliation
Jeff Nicole thank you